Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: Those franchises
are terrible, the modern incarnations of some
of these franchises that have been around
more than 20 years…
Film Courage: And aside from
student debt, let's suppose someone
has been fortunate enough to have their
education entirely covered. Let's talk about
the over reliance on an alma mater…I went
to this school therefore I deserve a job.
Chris: Yeah I'm not…I don't know the alma
mater thing (being part of a club), I don't
know. See I'm a person that I can meet almost
any stranger and find some level of connection,
we're both parents we both love cats we have a
love of Frank Herbert or like I can find some
connection I like football just because I like
watching live sporting events where there are
stakes involved but I don't take sports all that
seriously I do think that those club connections
that is one way to connect but when it comes to
people almost any type of person I can find a way
that we all connect so yeah I do think that
there's maybe an over-reliance on that as being
part of a club but I think that there's so many
different ways to connect with people whether it's
a shared passion for food or film or
maybe a place like the chug and monkey
bar in Austin Texas on sixth street I don't know
why that popped into my head but I love that bar
so like I just because I am a person that loves
to connect with people like i'll find some way
I do think maybe there is an over reliance
on the alma mater being the thing I tend to
connect with people the easiest way to connect
is through a passion for film and all types of
film I really am I do think it's important that
we have a balanced media diet oh what is that
a balanced media diet is absolutely critical in
the same way that what we put into our bodies
is just as important if you lived only on
fast food say Hollywood blockbuster movies
I find that first of all if you only ate
McDonald's there's already been a movie made about
that and it doesn't do good things to your body
right like fast food greasy food not good for you
balance and I feel like we don't pay
enough attention to our media diet
and the media diet has to be yes fine I'm gonna go
see that marvel movie right I'm gonna go see that
movie that a lot of movie these days they're just
like theme park rides they're not movies right
they're selling products and I'm going to balance
that out by seeing a really amazing documentary
or a small independent film made by a
filmmaker I've never heard of put out like
by a Gravitas Ventures or something or a 1091
or A24 one of these other companies well A24 is
Warner Brothers that's another story but
the orchard The Orchard yeah A24 is very
good taste if you ask oh they do I really do
love their the their how they curate the films
that they put out or an IFC, Participant yeah
yeah like have a balanced media diet if you
there's a whole group of Youtubers that
are on that that have made a living
clowning on giant franchises and I say I agree
with first of all I agree with many of them those
franchises are terrible the modern incarnations
of some of these franchises that have been around
more than 20 years they've sort of run it into the
ground but I feel like maybe you wouldn't be as
upset about them if you had a balanced media diet
meaning meaning yeah i'll see the latest whatever
forgettable big blockbuster movie but because
I have seen some smaller film this is a weird
example psycho gourmand or a movie a documentary
I would highly recommend called clapboard jungle
which is about it's about a filmmaker's
journey trying to actually find a way to make
money in this in crazy industry I think you
need to have a balanced media diet and that's
at least what my mission is with film thread is
we tend to champion filmmakers who make these
smaller movies because there are plenty of other
websites that cover Star Wars Marvel Pixar Disney
right those are all one company if I right Marvel
Pixar Star Wars Disney that's all one company
putting out the stuff it really is a monopoly
it's unfortunate that these big blockbusters
have that but those are okay to see but you should
not only see those it's just like within like see
one of those and then see a smaller film see one
of those see a documentary see one of those see
another documentary like break it up and really
look like whether it's like you're scrolling
through iTunes or voodoo or whatever one of those
services where you can purchase or rent movies and
look at the video on demand stuff that's just come
out you're gonna find some incredible stuff and
and that's where I feel very fortunate and that's
part of our mission is to say look at these movies
because if you only lived off the giant
franchise films you will find only disappointment
and so and so break it up a bit maybe you won't be
as upset about that so have a balanced media diet
so there's four food groups right and there's
four like you have your blockbusters you have
your documentaries you have your art house and
then maybe something with subtitles sure okay
I actually what I will say this I
put subtitles on when I don't have to
because you learned so much when I watched game of
thrones I knew all the characters names because I
watched it with with the closed captioning on it's
great it's it's really it's really fantastic so I
actually recommend closed captioning even if it's
a film that's in your the the language that you're
familiar with your native language is it's you'll
learn more because especially because a lot of it
is like you'll get some of the direction that's
directly out of the screenplay right like it's
really useful and thinking like a writer I think
that watching a movie with closed captioning
on in english even if you are an english
speaker is really useful so I tend to do that
I don't know is that I don't know if that's
a thing I do it I think I have friends who
think I'm crazy for doing it I find it incredibly
you'll learn a lot more about what you're watching
I know my limits I know what I'm good at and
I'm not and I tend to go towards my strengths
and and when I did stand up I don't think that
that was while I'm comfortable being in front of
an audience when I saw the guys that were really
good at it I was like oh the amount of effort like
it just was not for me and then and then
additionally hecklers too well it's not the
heckler so much that I didn't mind hecklers or
people in the audience that that the crowd work
is fun to me I love crowd work mainly because I
like people more than anything I love I just love
people I have now become my grandmother where I
have conversations with people in grocery lines
oh yeah yeah that's that's I've become that guy
but but are you the ones having the conversation
sorry to interrupt with the demo people the
demo people when they do the free samples
oh no you've really crossed over when you have
five hours no but I’ll like I don't know I just
feel like it's like getting out of our social
media bubble I think you if you only read social
media and especially Twitter which I think is
horrible horribly toxic and not a representation
of real life I think if you just go outside
and talk to people all of the the vitriol it's
not there people face to face speaking face
to face there's more that's communicated
by looking in someone's eyes and I think
unfortunately social media has has brought out
so many demons I mean maybe maybe it's a good
thing in the sense that those demons are online
and then they don't exist in the real world as
much but we're living in some really bizarre
times if I don't I think that's an understatement
yes now see I'm the one going off on tangents.
Questions For The Viewers: Please
give us a movie recommendation.